[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Data.
It's the great differentiator in
today's competitive landscape.
Every day, your business pulls
in huge quantities of it,
from web interactions
to inventory counts,
diagnostic reports
to consumer feedback.
And then it sits,
separated across systems,
unstructured, and disjointed.
Being able to look out
across all that data,
connect the dots, and
see the bigger picture
is key to your company's
success and survival.
Machine learning gives
you this ability--
the chance to view your
data in a whole new way.
Instead of following
code and commands,
it learns from what you compile
to find patterns and insights
that not only make you
smarter, but can revolutionize
how your business runs.
At Google, we use
machine learning
to optimize all our products,
from real-time traffic in Maps,
spam detection in Gmail, and
facial recognition in Photos.
And now we've designed a
platform especially for you.
Predict when to
ramp up production.
Know when your customers
are ready to upgrade.
Diagnose new diseases
with speed and accuracy.
The more data you bring to
it, the more unique insights
you're given, the
more opportunities
you have to redefine how
your enterprise runs.
This is the future of how
machines and people work
together to transform
how we all do business.
The technology is here
and it's waiting for you.
Will it make the difference
for your enterprise?